Dice resuelve la desigualdad para
"x" más 8 menor o igual que 6
y gráfica la solución,
entonces tenemos
"x" más 8 es menor o igual que 6,
resolvemos esta desigualdad para "x"
y la mejor manera de aislar a la "x"
es simplemente en este caso del lado izquierdo,
es simplemente deshacernos de este 8
y nos deshacemos de ese 8 simplemente restándolo
de ambos lados de la desigualdad
así que hagamos eso,
restamos 8 de ambos lados
y eso no va a cambiar el signo de la desigualdad,
entonces del lado izquierdo tenemos,
tenemos "x" más 8 menos 8
es igual a "x"
y del lado derecho tenemos
6 menos 8 es igual a -2,
"x" es menor o igual que -2,
y ya...
resolvimos la desigualdad,
"x" es menor o igual que -2 ahora,
vamos a graficar esto
en la recta numérica,
voy a dibujar aquí una recta numérica,
aquí pongo al 0,
aquí al 1,
aquí al -1, - 2, - 3
y queremos gráficar a todos los "x"
que son menor o igual que -2
dado que pueden ser igual a -2
entonces vamos a llenar este...
este  espacio
y
a todos los valores que son menor o igual que -2,
están en la solución,
si no tuviéramos este igual
y solamente tuviéramos el menor
entonces,
aquí no tocaría al 2
pero como es menor o igual que -2
entonces vamos a incluir al 2
y todos los valores que son menor que eso también están incluidos.
Ahora podemos verificarlo con algunos valores, tomemos por ejemplo,
al -3, el -3 debe funcionar,
entonces,
-3 más 8 es igual a 5
y 5 es menor o igual que 6,
así que sí funciona.
Si lo intentamos con el -1 no debe funcionar,
entonces, vamos a verificar eso
-1 más 8 eso es igual a 7
y 7 no es menor o igual que 6
entonces,
estamos en lo correcto.